bonjour à tous La séance est ouverte sur
LCP nous sommes le 24 novembre 2022
c'est une journée dite d'initiative
parlementaire c'est-à-dire qu'elle est
réservée à un groupe d'opposition qui
dispose de la séance jusqu'à minuit ce
jeudi là c'est la France insoumise qui
fait son ordre du jour à 9 heures quand
s’ouvre les débats le groupe a décidé de
porter un texte unique à la discussion
une proposition de loi pour inscrire le
droit à l'IVG dans la Constitution la
parole est à Mathilde panot présidente
du groupe la France insoumise à
l'Assemblée nationale rien n'est jamais
définitivement acquis il suffira d'une
crise politique économique ou religieuse
pour que les droits des femmes soient
remis en question votre vie durant vous
devrez rester vigilante
ces mots de Simone de Beauvoir furent
prononcés en 1974
à la lumière du présent il nous livre un
constat terrible l'histoire des droits
des femmes à quelque chose
d'implacablement répétitif car s'il est
en invariant de notre civilisation
humaine c'est la domination des hommes
sur les femmes et les véhicules de
contrôle sur leur corps les États-Unis
la Pologne la Hongrie l'Italie est
d'autres pays en Europe ce sont déjà
engouffrés dans cette guerre impitoyable
réduisant les femmes à un sort misérable
nous savons qu'à chaque sursaut
réactionnaire les droits des femmes sont
en première ligne j'ai une pensée émue
pour Isabelle et agnieschka deux femmes
polonaises mortes de ne pas avoir pu
avorter dans de bonnes conditions
car collègue la restriction des droits
sexuels et reproductifs n'a jamais
abouti jamais à une diminution du nombre
d'avortements les femmes ont toujours
avorté même au péril de leur vie avant
1975 si les mieux lotis partaient à
l'étranger les autres ingurgités de
l'eau oxygénée du détergent du vinaigre
s'introduisez dans l'utérus une aiguille
à tricoter un épi de blé une brosse à
dents de l'eau savonneuse pour mettre un
terme à leur grossesse voici la réalité
des sévices que des femmes pouvaient
s'infliger entraînant parfois leur mort
car oui la seule conséquence de la
privation des femmes du droit à avorter
c'est l'avortement clandestin et le plus
souvent la mort le destin de ces lois et
pour les femmes est toujours finesse le
texte défendu par le groupe LFI sur son
ordre du jour réservé vise à inscrire
deux droits dans la Constitution le
droit à l'IVG mais aussi le droit à la
contraception s'appuyant sur le recul
rester dans certains pays comme aux
États-Unis la chef de fil des insoumis à
l'Assemblée nationale estime que ces
deux droits doivent être protégés en
France
introduire le droit à la
contraction dans notre Constitution
c'est conjurer ici cette effroi qui nous
saisit lorsqu'ils des femmes font
l'objet de coups de boutoir il s'agit de
donner un socle à notre vigilance afin
de parer au basculement imprévisible
dont seul l'histoire humaine a le secret
certes nous le faisons en conscience
qu'il est de marbre assez tenaces pour y
graver un droit pour l'éternité mais les
droits fondamentaux à nos yeux doivent
bénéficier de la plus grande garantie
que nous pouvons leur conférer cette
proposition de loi vise à se prémunir
d'une régression en faisant de l'attente
à ses droits l'attache la plus ardu
possible
quiconque souhaitant s'y attaquer devra
avoir les mains liées notre souhait est
clair nous ne voulons laisser aucune
chance aux personnes hostiles à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et à la contraception
voici la question posée en creux de ce
texte souhaitez-vous laisser une chance
pour vendeur du droit à l'avortement et
la contraception si votre réponse est
non vous n'avez plus qu'à le voter car
comme nous vous trouveriez insupportable
en recul sur ses droits en revanche si
vous souhaitez leur laisser une chance
soyez clair sur le fond car à vous
entendre il n'y aurait ici que des
obstructeurs mais personne d'hostile à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
cessez d'avancer masquer quel propos les
femmes n'ont-elles pas entendu sur le
droit à disposer d'elle-même vos
amendements nous servent les pensifs les
plus écoles les femmes devraient avoir
l'autorisation de leur compagnon de leur
mari pour avorter les mineurs devraient
être privés de ce droit l'embryon et le
fœtus serait des enfants à naître
l'avortement devrait être présenté comme
un drame oui l'histoire est quelque
chose de terriblement répétitif des
années 70 à nos jours la teneur des
débats n'a pas changé
ici même les frontières s'effacent le
prétendu cordon sanitaire qui sépare les
différentes nuances de droites devient
lâche ainsi les amendements LR se
confondent avec ceux de l'extrême droite
tous deux réunis dans une même passion
en style droit des femmes un continuum
misogyne se dessine sous nos yeux
collègue
vous résistances n'ont rien d'original
tant le contrôle du corps des femmes
s'inscrit dans une histoire millénaire
sachez que la bigoterie parlementaire
est un oxymore le sort des femmes n'a
pas à dépendre de vos conservatismes
personnels vous pensez à appartenir à
vos convictions quand vos convictions
n'appartiennent qu'à la longue histoire
de la domination masculine ailleurs vos
avatars voient leur monde mourir et
tenter d'y donner un dernier sursis
c'est donc dans ce moment précis de
l'histoire que le Parlement sonnerait a
voté cette proposition de loi en
introduisant ses droits dans la
Constitution la France s'illustrerait
comme une nation pionnière en matière
des droits des femmes c'est avec cette
certitude que nous avons collectivement
réfléchi aux différentes rédactions
possibles de ce texte il s'agit d'un
travail transportant et je tiens ici à
saluer à remercier mes collègues
monsieur Balan madame violent madame
Baptiste Madame faussillon et Monsieur
Yordanov
introduire le droit à la contraception
et à l'avortement dans notre
Constitution c'est aussi formuler la
promesse suivante aux nouvelles
générations vos mères ne seront pas
mieux protégés que vous c'est faire acte
de progrès humain en affirmant
collectivement à la nécessité de ses
droits c'est une manière de briser enfin
cette partition historique entre la
sphère privée et politique voulant que
les droits sexuels et reproductifs
soient un propre à entrer dans notre
texte suprême les droits à l'avortement
et à la contraception vont de pair et ne
sont pas une affaire de bonne femme ces
droits ne doivent être cantonnés à la
sphère du domicile assignant les femmes
à des tâches silencieuses de
reproduction sociale non les droits
sexuels et reproductifs sont la
condition de possibilité de notre
communauté politique et relève de
l'égalité et de la citoyenneté
j'achève en vous disant que je ne suis
pas venue seule ici une pétition adore
et déjà recueilli 160 000 signatures
citoyennes pour l'inscription de ces
droits dans la Constitution
car derrière une proposition de loi il y
a toujours une foule une foule guidée
par une Alassane quête d'émancipation de
maîtrise de sa propre existence une
foule de femmes et d'hommes de
militantes infatigables d'associations
et de collectifs sans lesquels un droit
n'a fleur pas auprès du grand nombre
comme une nécessité
collègue aujourd'hui nous pouvons tenir
le fil de l'histoire le vote de ce texte
sera je l'espère une forme d'hommage à
leur juste combat je vous remercie le
gouvernement soutient la proposition de
loi constitutionnelle de la France
insoumise à la tribune le garde des
sceaux Eric Dupont-Moretti défend une
réforme indispensable la nécessité de
graver dans le marbre de la Constitution
un droit fondamental
la parole est à Monsieur Eric
Dupont-Moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice
[Applaudissements]
madame
la présidente mesdames messieurs les
députés
après le débat au Sénat le mois dernier
c'est l'Assemblée nationale qui examine
aujourd'hui
une proposition de loi constitutionnelle
déposée par madame la Présidente panneau
visant à protéger et à garantir le droit
fondamental à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse
laissez-moi vous dire en préambule
que j'en suis heureux car le 13 juillet
dernier j'avais solennellement déclaré
devant cette assemblée qu'en tant que
garde des sceaux je soutiendrai toutes
les initiatives parlementaires qui
viseraient à
constitutionnaliser le droit à l'IVG
[Applaudissements]
le voici donc au rendez-vous pour dire à
cette assemblée comme je l'ai dit au
Sénat modernier que le Gouvernement est
favorable à l'inscription du droit à
l'IVG dans notre Constitution
l'histoire fourmille d'exemples de
liberté fondamentale que l'on croyait
acquise et qui pourtant ont été rayés
d'un trait de plumes par les événements
les crises ou les lames de fond
et c'est encore plus vrai lorsqu'il
s'agit des droits des femmes parce que
nos sociétés les ont en réalité bafoués
durant des siècles
les événements qui se déroulent hors de
nos frontières
partout dans le monde
nous le démontre avec force et acuité
c'est ce que nous rappelle la décision
de la Cour suprême des États-Unis de
juin dernier le droit à l'avortement
qu'on croyait acquis depuis 50 ans
ne l'était en réalité pas du tout
désormais l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse
n'est plus qu'un droit
les plus un droit garantis par la
Constitution fédérale des états
et les États fédérés sont donc libres de
l'interdire et pour certains d'entre eux
ils ne se prive pas de le faire
parce que nous avons en effet désormais
la preuve que
j'ai aucune démocratie
pas même l'une des plus grandes d'entre
toutes n'est à l'abri il nous faut
rester évidemment toujours
particulièrement vigilant
les auteurs de la présente proposition
de loi madame la Présidente panot
propose d'inscrire le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
dans notre Constitution et j'entends
déjà murmuré dans un premier temps
et puis s'élever des voix pour dire que
l'exemple américain n'est pas
transposable en France parce que le
droit à l'IVG il est bien protégé il est
vrai que nos institutions fonctionnent
différemment et que le Conseil
constitutionnel français n'est pas la
Cour suprême américaine il est vrai
aussi que le droit à l'IVG a été
conforté au fil des ans depuis qu'il a
été consacré pour la première fois dans
notre droit par la loi Veil du 17
janvier 1975
je pense ici à la dernière loi en date
du 2 mars 2022 porté par votre ancienne
collègue Albane Gaillot qui a allongé le
délai légal pour recourir à l'évier en
le portant de 12 à 14 semaines je pense
aussi aux lois qui ont précédé comme par
exemple la loi du 4 août 2014 pour
l'égalité réelle entre les hommes et les
femmes qui a supprimé le critère de la
situation en détresse ou encore avant la
loi dite neyers du 27 janvier
1993 qui a dépénalisé l'auto avortement
est créé le délit d'entrave à l'IVG
pour autant
vous le savez gravé dans le marbre de
notre Constitution le droit fondamental
à l'IVG me paraît plus que nécessaire en
ces temps agités d'abord
cette inscription aurait une valeur
symbolique et bien sûr également
juridique
la constitution et le texte fondateur de
notre État de droit le socle commun des
valeurs et des libertés fondamentales de
notre société inscrire l'IVG dans notre
texte fondamental permettrait de
consacrer comme un droit fondamental et
non simplement comme une liberté
autonomie ensuite
parce qu'il faut bien convenir de cette
évidence changer la constitution et
beaucoup plus difficile que changer la
loi aujourd'hui protéger au niveau
législatif le droit à l'IVG sera demain
protéger au niveau constitutionnel cela
signifie que le législateur ne pourra
pas le remettre
substantiellement en cause seul le
pouvoir constituant le pourrait la
démocratie
l'État de droit et les droits
fondamentaux sont des biens précieux il
est de notre devoir de les préserver
alors ne prenons pas de risques et
protégeons le droit à l'IVG
que le droit à l'avortement largement
partagé au sein de l'Union européenne à
toutefois et vous l'avez rappelé madame
la Présidente panot était récemment
remis en question par plusieurs de nos
voisins européens
en Hongrie
par exemple
les femmes ne peuvent plus avorter
sans avoir préalablement dû écouter le
battement de cœur du fœtus
certes il met difficile bien sûr de me
mettre à la place des femmes qui
subissent cela mais je voudrais qu'on
s'arrête un instant
dans le silence et le recueillement
peut-être sur la violence inouïe qu'une
telle obligation
inflige aux femmes hongroises
je le dis tout net tant que je serai
garde des sceaux et tant que cette
majorité gouvernera notre pays nous ne
permettrons jamais qu'une telle violence
soit imposée aux femmes françaises
[Applaudissements]
l'avenir
charrie pourtant sa part d'incertitude
c'est pourquoi nous voulons
constitutionnaliser ce droit
d'autant qu'il ne fait d'ailleurs
l'objet d'aucune harmonisation dans
l'Union européenne en effet le président
de la République a lancé vous le savez
en janvier dernier le chantier ambitieux
mais au combien nécessaire de
l'inscription du droit à l'IVG au sein
de la Charte des droits fondamentaux de
l'Union européenne pour que l'Europe
qui nous a déjà apporté la paix apporte
au droit des femmes la protection
qu'elle mérite
mesdames messieurs les députés
ne vous trompez pas inscrire aujourd'hui
le droit à l'IVG dans notre Constitution
n'est pas une mesure gadget
un artifice de communication ou un
mouvement de panique face à un exemple
lointain
inscrire le droit à l'IVG cette liberté
fondamentale et inaliénable de la femme
c'est une sécurité pour toutes les
femmes de notre pays les temps troublés
et les remous ne sont jamais loin dans
le frêle esquif de la démocratie
faites en sorte que nous nous
la montillons pas de ne pas avoir
sauvegardé aujourd'hui ce droit
fondamental qui pourrait être remise en
cause demain mais que les choses soient
claires il ne s'agit pas là d'une
entreprise aisée je le dis avec gravité
on ne doit toucher à la constitution que
d'une main tremblante c'est pourquoi
il nous faut avoir à l'esprit que la
rédaction que vous retiendrez
aujourd'hui
lundi prochain ou lors des prochains
débats sera évidemment
déterminante une rédaction inadaptée
pour être en effet
conduire soit à consacrer un accès
absolument sans conditions à l'IVG je
pense par exemple à des IVG bien au-delà
de la limite légale en vigueur
une écriture mal soupeée pourrait
également s'avérer trop rigide et
empêcher une adaptation possible du
dispositif actuel si celle-ci s'avérait
nécessaire comme cela a déjà été le cas
au mois de mars dernier
il nous faudra alors au cours des débats
restés très vigilants sur ces possibles
effets de bord il nous faudra également
rester vigilant sur le choix de la place
à laquelle inscrire le droit à l'IVG
dans la Constitution afin de donner tout
son sens à cette reconnaissance et toute
sa cohérence au regard des autres
dispositions constitutionnelles
par ailleurs je ne veux pas ternir votre
notre enthousiasme votre enthousiasme
il nous faut désormais tenir compte du
vote du Sénat du 19 octobre dernier
car oui car oui modifier la Constitution
nécessite que la proposition de révision
soit adaptée je le rappelle dans des
termes
identiques dans les deux chambres or les
sénateurs ont rejeté d'emblée la
proposition de la sénatrice Mélanie
Vogel qui ressemblait peu ou proue à la
version dont nous débattrons aujourd'hui
je sais que de nombreux amendements vont
être débattus et c'est le rôle du
Parlement que d'affiner bien sûr les
textes qu'il examinent toutefois je me
dois de rappeler ce principe de réalité
mener à bout ce chantier historique
nécessite de prendre en compte
toutes les contraintes politiques en
présence dans les deux chambres c'est
pourquoi
je le dis sans embase je suis réservé
sur l'écriture actuelle qui n'a à mon
sens quasiment aucune chance d'aboutir
au regard de mes discussions au Sénat le
moins dernier
si je me réjouis
que votre commission des Lois est quant
à elle adoptait deux textes
je peux vous dire d'emblée que la
commission des Lois du Sénat n'a pas
accepté un texte qui
constitutionnaliserait également l'accès
à la contraception c'est pourquoi
conformément à mon engagement et aux
déclarations fortes de la première
ministre je soutiendrai les propositions
qui se concentrent sur l'IVG car la
Constitution ne peut se modifier en
laissant de côté l'une des deux champs
si nous voulons donner à ce chantier
commun toutes les chances d'aboutir il
nous faut faire preuve mesdames et
messieurs de réalisme sur ce point
l'écriture actuelle de la proposition de
loi de la présidente berger et de votre
collègue Marie-Pierre ricin nous semble
plus à même d'aboutir
mais j'ai noté madame la Présidente
panneau
que des amendements avaient été déposés
en ce sens je les lis avec sagesse
toutefois la rédaction
idoine à la fois ambitieuse et calibrée
à la fois fidèle à l'esprit de notre
Constitution est fidèle à notre ambition
reste encore à dénicher c'est pourquoi
le travail du Parlement doit se
poursuivre ainsi que l'indiquer le
président de la République la semaine
dernière
je veux d'ailleurs saluer
de manière républicaine l'ensemble des
initiatives qui se sont faites jour dans
les deux chambres qu'elles émanent de
l'opposition ou de la majorité
je vous livre le fond de ma pensée
je reste optimiste car le Sénat n'a
rejeté le texte que de 17 voix
il n'a donc manqué que 17 voix
pour ce que je considère être un échec
porteur d'espoir
mais si j'ose dire le Sénat
à lui assumer son vote de rejet
tout en se montrant
particulièrement ouvert au dialogue
ce que je constate avec tristesse
c'est que sur un sujet aussi grave que
celui-là
on puisse au fond se livrer à ce petit
jeu d'obstruction parlementaire
et si vous voulez que
je vous dise
j'observe
que
ce sont les mêmes
qui nous disent qu'il ne faut soit
disant pas importer les débats
américains en France qui en fait
importe les pires méthodes américaines
avec ce matin une mauvaise leçon de
Philippe bustering
en bon français naturellement
acheter un dictionnaire franco-anglais
vous verrez c'est une expression
utilise c'est une c'est une expression
c'est une expression parce que je peux
vous le traduire en russe aussi si vous
voulez
la nuit dernière ce sont encore la nuit
dernière ce sont encore vous allez
comprendre des dizaines des dizaines
d'amendements de sous amendements qui
ont été déposés
sans répit
et ce alors même que le sujet qui nous
réunit ce matin
particulièrement important
particulièrement graves de quoi
parlons-nous nous parlons du droit des
femmes à disposer de leur corps le droit
à l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
est une condition indispensable à
l'émancipation des femmes sans laquelle
l'égalité
principe absolument cardinal de notre
République en vertu de l'article 2 de la
Constitution ne saurait être pleinement
respecté je répète pour ces messieurs
dames qui produisent des amendements
comme en produirait des gravillons pour
gripper la machine la volonté politique
est là le Gouvernement est favorable à
l'inscription de l'IVG dans la
Constitution
l'Assemblée nationale je l'espère sera
favorable à l'IVG dans la Constitution
et je ne perds pas espoir avec un
dialogue nourri
et un travail approfondi le Sénat sera
peut-être favorable à l'IVG dans la
Constitution c'est pourquoi je vous le
dis à tous
comme je l'ai dit à vos collègues
sénateurs le mois dernier travaillons
encore cheminons ensemble afin de mener
à bien cette réforme historique pour
dire avec la plus grande force qui soit
aux générations actuelles et futures de
françaises mesdames votre corps vous
appartient pointe à la ligne
une large partie de l'hémicycle est
favorable à l'inscription du droit à
l'IVG dans la constitution et le texte a
le soutien d'une partie de la droite et
de l'extrême droite mais certains au
rassemblement national et chez les
républicains dénonce l'absence de limite
à ce droit résultat des courses ils ont
déposé des dizaines et des dizaines
d'amendements en séance publique faisant
durer les débats il y a un vrai paradoxe
il y a un vrai paradoxe parce que les
arguments que vous avancez effectivement
sont des arguments qui vont en faveur du
fait de dire attention dès qu'on
constitutions analyses il y a un certain
nombre de problèmes et le vrai paradoxe
c'est que le comité veille de 2008 qui
s'est penché sur cette question est-il
ou non opportun inscrire des droits et
des principes fondamentaux nouveaux dans
la Constitution avait répondu par la
négative ce comité était présidé par
Simone Weil elle-même évidemment il
n'était pas spécifiquement cas de l'IVG
mais cette question a été abordée donc
il y a vraiment un débat de fond et je
pense que nous ne devons pas esquiver
les incidences lorsque l'on inscrit
quelque chose dans la Constitution en
fait ce que l'on oublie de dire et ce
qui n'a pas été mentionné ce matin c'est
tout le risque systémique parce que
quand vous inscrivez un droit et bien ce
qui peut se passer on peut en affaiblir
d'autres notamment quand il s'agit de
loi or ces deux cela dont il s'agissait
c'est-à-dire que en réalité il faut voir
l'incidence globale lorsque l'on fait
quelque chose quant à la loi Veil ce que
je voudrais rappeler ce qui a été fait
excellemment par notre collègue Josiane
cornew il y a quelques instants c'était
de dire que c'est une loi d'équilibre et
cette loi elle avait un objectif
principal c'était évidemment consacré la
liberté de la femme mais c'était aussi
la protection de la vie à naître et vous
voyez bien que cette question là nous
devons bien pouvoir l'aborder parce que
c'est de cela dont il s'agit est-ce que
l'on constitue analyse un équilibre ou
est-ce que l'on constitutionnalise
quelque chose qui serait déséquilibré
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
portons cet amendement qui serait une
manière de maintenir un équilibre merci
monsieur le député allez-y chers
collègues
moi je voudrais recadrer le un petit peu
le débat voilà j'étais chirurgien je
n'exerce plus mais j'ai connu l'époque
avant 75 et après 1975 je peux vous dire
que remettre en question même de façon
conceptuelle le droit à l'IVG serait une
catastrophe j'ai connu les réparations
j'ai connu les morts j'ai connu les
urgences voilà et donc
[Applaudissements]
il est clair que pour moi ce débat je le
suis depuis ce matin à créer beaucoup
d'émotions et je vous demande d'en tenir
compte ensuite quand j'entends dire que
c'est par un manque de moyens qu'on
pourrait pas actuellement assumer les
demandes d'IVG je pense que c'est un
très mauvais argument parce que dans les
années 80 il n'y avait pas de pénurie du
chirurgien il n'avait pas de pénurie de
structure et les obstacles c'était les
médecins qui ne voulaient pas assumer le
droit de faire des IVG et leur argument
je l'ai vécu c'était de dire je ne suis
pas formé pour faire les IVG alors que
la formation d'un chirurgien bien
entendu permet de faire des IVG donc moi
je vous dis réfléchissez faites
attention c'est un sujet qui peut être
catastrophique parce que la protection
du corps de la femme etc tout ce qui a
été dit c'est fondamental et ça mérite
une inscription dans la Constitution
merci monsieur le député
nous allons maintenant procéder au
scrutin je vais donc mettre au voile
amendement 48 qui a reçu un double avis
défavorable commission et gouvernement
je vous prie de bien vous regagner vos
places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 272
exprimés 231 majorité 116 pour 35 contre
196 l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas adopté
nous arrivons avec l'examen de cet
article unique avec les amendements et
sous amendements que nous allons
discuter sur le fond effectivement de
cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle et la question on va
le voir c'est pas pour ou contre l'IVG
la question c'est bien pour ou contre
l'IVG inconditionnel c'est on voit bien
qu'il y a deux conceptions et on va
pouvoir le voir à travers tous ces
amendements il y a ceux qui font le
droit à l'IVG uniquement sur la liberté
de la femme en disant c'est la liberté
de la femme et à partir de là il y a un
droit qui doit effectivement être
exprimé et qui s'oppose à tout autre
considération il y a une autre
conception qui est celle que nous
défendons qui consiste à dire bien sûr
qu'il y a cette liberté de la femme mais
il y a un autre principe qui est celui
de la Protection de la Vie à être
et qu'il faut trouver cet équilibre cet
équilibre il se trouve difficilement les
débats de la loiveil montrent bien que
ça avait été douloureux comme débat mais
c'était à la fois dire oui il y a bien
une liberté de la femme à disposer de
son corps c'est pas un droit absolu
et il y a il y a la protection de la
bien-être parce qu'effectivement c'est
pour ça qu'il y a un certain nombre de
conditions notamment de délai et la
question que je voudrais vous poser
madame le rapporteur c'est le ministre
c'est dire pourquoi vous maintenez
encore des conditions de délai si vous
n'êtes incapable de reconnaître la
protection de la bien-être si vous êtes
uniquement sur la liberté de la femme
rien ne devrait s'opposer à cette
liberté
ni condition particulière comme il
pouvait exister soit ou qui continue à
exister aujourd'hui avec effectivement
ces délais ces délais ils sont là parce
qu'effectivement il y a une
interrogation qui reste un mystère qui
se pose à l'humanité depuis ses débuts
de savoir ce qu'est un embryon ce qu'est
un fœtus c'est pas nous aujourd'hui qui
allons y répondre on va continuer à
s'interroger chacun et aussi
collectivement sur ce cette ce mystère
de la procréation mais il faut qu'on
puisse dire oui il y a bien un principe
de protection de la vie à nette à côté
du principe de la liberté la femme je
vous remercie Ménard
merci madame la Présidente la loi du 17
janvier 1975 sur l'IVG et non dans son
article premier que la loi garantit le
respect de tout être humain dès le
commencement de la vie il ne saurait
être porté atteinte à ce principe qu'en
cas de nécessité et selon les conditions
définies par la présente loi ce principe
législatif était lors du débat de la loi
de 75 un élément essentiel qui avait
conduit à accepter une suspension
c'était le terme qui avait été employé
par l'article 2 de la loi des
dispositions du Code pénal réprimant la
pratique de l'avortement il s'agissait
d'équilibrer les droits de la mer et
ceux de l'embryon en posant une règle
dérogatoire au respect de tout être
humain dès le commencement de la vie
alors si votre proposition de loi
constitutionnelle était votée elle
s'imposerait à cette législation qui
deviendrait en quelque sorte sans objet
c'est l'ensemble de l'édifice législatif
relatif à l'IVG qu'il faudrait modifier
procéder assez modifications alors que
le recours à l'IVG est en aucune façon
menacée en France je vous rappelle qu'il
y a plus de 220 000 IVG par an en France
sous la pression d'une décision de la
Cour suprême des États-Unis qui n'a
aucun rapport avec le système français
me paraît parfaitement
inutile et dangereux pour notre
Constitution comme j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le rappeler en discussion
générale mes chers collègues vous agitez
les peurs pour faire croire aux Français
que l'avortement serait menacé en France
quelle imposture citez-moi une décision
du Conseil constitutionnel qui aurait
tenté de le remettre en cause vous n'en
trouverez pas et pour cause il n'y en a
pas c'est pourquoi je demande la
suppression de votre article je vous
remercie merci madame la députée
l'amendement 192 madame Blin merci
madame la Présidente mais c'est un
amendement de suppression est en réalité
un amendement de cohérence
parce que après avoir modifié l'ordre du
jour au détriment de discussions autour
de la question du pouvoir d'achat que
vous avez refusé de mener dans cette
hémicycle vous avez et vous ne l'assumez
vous ne l'assumerez d'ailleurs
certainement pas
essayez et vous avez trouvé un accord
avec le gouvernement pour réussir à
trouver une nouvelle formulation et
éviter un nouveau débat constitutionnel
la semaine prochaine donc en réalité
vous saviez pertinemment que le
dispositif initialement écrit ne tenez
pas et ne pouvez pas être adopté tel que
donc clairement aujourd'hui voter la
suppression et maintenant la suppression
est tout à fait cohérent sur le fond
vous importez un débat qui vient des
États-Unis alors même qu'en France il
n'est absolument pas question de
remettre
une entrave quelconque à l'IVG la
jurisprudence du Conseil constitutionnel
est tout à fait constante à ce sujet et
d'ailleurs je rappellerai à la à
l'ensemble des élus tenant et peu parti
prenante et fervent défenseur d'Emmanuel
Macron qu'en 2018 Agnès Buzyn Nicole
Belloubet qui était alors ministre avait
affirmé devant le Parlement l'inutilité
d'inscrire le droit à l'IVG dans la
Constitution
en raison de l'extrême solidité de sa
protection constitutionnelle donc
l'amendement de suppression est
aujourd'hui parfaitement opportun merci
madame la députée le 264 Monsieur Le Fur
oui
ça a été dit par ma collègue madame
blinds a été dit par Josiane cœur de
Louis également on importe un débat
américain qui n'a rien à voir ici le
débat américain c'est un débat entre le
pouvoir fédéral et le pouvoir des états
ici nous savons un seul législateur il y
a donc pas ce sujet vous voulez
absolument le faire alors que se
pratique en France 220000 avortement
est-ce que certains veulent l'augmenter
ce chiffre j'ose espérer que non donc
c'est pas le sujet nous ne sommes
dominés en matière de nombre
d'avortement que par un seul pays
la Russie monsieur Poutine est-ce que
c'est un exemple je crois pas c'est
révélateur surtout des troubles des
difficultés des drames de ce pays donc
nous considérons que cet amendement dans
la Constitution n'est pas nécessaire
qu'il n'est pas souhaité je vous renvoie
également à Simone Veil même qui a
présidé une commission constitutionnelle
en 2008 et qui avait dit son opposition
à la constitution de l'avortement à la
constitutionnalisation de l'avortement
je vous renvoie à Madame brune Pivet qui
disait la même chose il y a quelques
mois je vous renvoie à Philippe Bas qui
s'est exprimé au Sénat Philippa fut le
collaborateur de Simone Veil il y avait
un équilibre dans les dispositions qui
étaient mises en avant par Simone Veil
il y avait un équilibre dans ce fameux
discours du 26 novembre de 74 que je
vous invite à relire et bien cet
équilibre vous êtes en train de le
casser c'est ça le sujet et c'est pour
ça que nous sommes mobilisés nous
considérons que ces affaires sociétales
ne peuvent pas être prises avec des
slogans mais doivent être prises avec
toutes les précautions nécessaires
merci monsieur le député madame le
rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente évidemment je
vais être défavorable assez trois
amendements de suppression et je veux
répondre à certains des arguments qui
ont été avancés et qui seront ré-avancés
madame Ménard vous dites l'avortement et
le droit à l'avortement n'est pas en
danger aujourd'hui en France et en
quelque sorte madame Blin vous l'avez
dit aussi nous sommes en train
d'importer un débat des États-Unis je
voudrais dire d'abord que c'est faux
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord vous avez
raison la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel va a toujours été en
faveur du droit à l'avortement mais
parce qu'on l'avait saisi sur des sur
des textes qui allaient justement
progrès sur le droit à l'avortement si
le Conseil constitutionnel était saisi
sur les amendements que vous avez déposé
madame Ménard parce qu'au fond vous
cherchez des prétextes parce que la
question n'est pas est-ce que on veut
inscrire ou pas le droit à l'IVG dans la
Constitution pour vous il est étant pour
ou contre le droit à l'avortement c'est
ça que vous êtes en train de poser
pourquoi parce que si le Conseil
constitutionnel était saisi par les
amendements de Madame Ménard qui propose
que le mari ou le compagnon puisse
réussir à une femme d'avorter c'est ce
que vous proposez dans vos amendements
lorsque vous pourrez aller vers des
questions de délai vers des questions de
réduction des gratuité et bien je vous
le dis ça peut arriver dans notre pays
et nous avons aujourd'hui dans le groupe
de 89 députés rassemblement national des
députés qui sont capables de dire après
avoir génocide les enfants français à
raison de 200000 par an on doit
maintenant les remplacer à tour de bras
par des migrants qui sont capables de
dire de comparer l'allongement de délai
de l'avortement à 14 semaines au
génocide arménien rwandais à la Shoah au
crime de daesh excusez-moi du peu l'IVG
reste un délit donc un acte intrase avec
moi mauvais vous êtes capable de dire au
moment de l'anniversaire de la loi
veille sinistre anniversaire hommage aux
millions de victimes de l'avortement non
à la culture de la mort oui à la vie ou
encore l'avortement est un génocide de
masse donc oui aujourd'hui cette
question pourrait se poser si nous la
posons dans la question de la
Constitution c'est parce que nous
pensons le temps long
et le temps long permet justement
d'inscrire une protection supplémentaire
sur la question du droit à l'avortement
qui je crois est nécessaire aussi dans
notre pays surtout quand on regarde ce
qui se passe y compris en Europe je
termine sur un point trouver les
prétextes que vous le souhaitez pour ne
pas dire que vous êtes contre
l'avortement mais juste la question qui
est posée c'est est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord pour inscrire l'avortement je
le dis le droit à l'avortement tel qu'il
est aujourd'hui en termes de délai en
termes de gratuité et autres tel qu'il
est aujourd'hui dans ma constitution où
est-ce que en refusant de l'inscrire
dans la Constitution vous fragilisez le
droit à l'avortement dans notre pays
merci Madame la rapporteur monsieur le
garde des sceaux
et si madame la députée Ménard
légiférée c'était aussi prévoir
mais vous dites c'est un débat
oui ben attendez c'est pas votre tour de
parole vous allez me laisser finir mon
propos si vous le voulez bien
et si Madame Ménard disait avant d'être
interrompu légiférer c'était prévoir
alors vous me dites oui l'Atlantique
nous sépare de tout cela mais pardon de
vous le dire qui sont ici les amis de
Monsieur Trump
qui
qui sont les amis de Monsieur Orban qui
pardonnez-moi
pardonnez-moi on mis un système de
torture qui consiste à obliger les
femmes qui veulent se faire avorter et
pardon de le dire on n'avorte jamais par
plaisir je suis un homme ça a été
rappelé tout à l'heure mais enfin je
pense avoir suffisamment de sensibilité
pour le comprendre on oblige ces femmes
à écouter le cœur battant du foetus
qu'elle porte dans leur ventre et qui
madame Ménard est proche du gouvernement
italien qui déjà a manifesté un certain
nombre de restrictions quant aux droites
à l'avortement alors prévoir l'avenir
ça n'est pas non plus madame Ménard
regardez le Conseil constitutionnel tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui et en qui les
républicains ont toute confiance c'est
l'imaginer comme il pourrait être dans
20 ans voyez-vous et pardon de vous dire
qui si ce n'est
l'une des portes-paroles du FN Madame
Laure La Valette a souhaité en 2014
abrogée le droit à l'avortement dans une
tribune qu'elle a signé et enfin ça
vient d'être rappelé quand vous évoquez
les avortements vous parlez de milliers
de victimes alors que chez vous chez
vous on envisage de laisser les migrants
monsieur Odoul mourir de froid à la
frontière polonaise
le rassemblement national défend lui
l'inscription dans la Constitution des
articles du code de la santé publique
qui se rapporte à l'avortement mais le
RN estime dans le même temps que ce
droit à l'IVG n'est pas menacé en France
c'est en tout cas la position de Marine
Le Pen au début des débats je
considère que il y a une vraie
malhonnêteté encore une fois à faire
croire que la question est de savoir si
on est pour ou contre la possibilité de
recourir à une IVG c'est évidemment pas
la question qui est ici posée puisque je
le rappelle pour la énième fois pas un
seul mouvement politique en France
représentatif n'est pour le retrait de
cette possibilité pour les femmes mais
il y a un problème de rédaction non mais
vous pouvez hurler tout ce que vous
voulez ça n'y changera rien
il y a un problème de rédaction dans
votre
proposition le problème de rédaction et
le suivant et je crois que quand on
touche à la constitution effectivement
il faut le faire avec une tremblante et
le problème il est double il est d'abord
que dans la rédaction que vous proposez
il y a une forme d'inconditionnalité
c'est à dire qu'il n'y a pas de délai ça
veut dire que sur le fondement de votre
rédaction pourrait être réclamé demain
d'ailleurs c'est déjà le cas par le
syndrome d'association l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse jusqu'à 9 mois
donc à deux mois quatre mois cinq mois
et ça clairement nous y sommes
radicalement opposés pardon et nous le
disons il y a également un problème car
je ne suis pas sûr que compte tenu de
cette rédaction la clause de conscience
des personnels de santé soient préservés
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vous
propose une solution qui normalement
devrait plaire à l'intégralité de cette
hémicycle et qui consiste à
constitutionnaliser la loi veulent telle
qu'elle existe actuellement c'est à dire
les articles du code de la santé
publique qui sont l'intégralité des
article qui
propose encore une fois cet accès qui le
règlemente qui en exprime les conditions
comme ça l'on est sûr qu'il n'y aura pas
dans votre esprit de régression et nous
sommes sur nous qu'il n'y aura pas une
augmentation inconsidérée des délais
contre lesquels nous sommes et vous le
savez merci
après une longue discussion en séance
publique et moult amendement débattus
aprement un accord transpartisan et
finalement trouvé
Erwan balanand député de la majorité et
Mathilde panot chef de fil des insoumis
à l'Assemblée défendent un amendement
unique pour inscrire le droit à l'IVG
dans la Constitution en abandonnant
toute référence à la contraception
extrait de séance
grandement faisant l'objet de sous
amendements le 231
merci madame la Présidente donc cet
amendement est le fruit d'un travail
commun mené par divers groupes de cette
assemblée nous avons su dans l'intérêt
de ce que nous du résultat que nous
souhaitions avoir faire fille de nos
différences et je tiens à le signaler
nous sommes pas toujours d'accord mais
là-dessus nous étions d'accord et je
remercie Mathilde panot et tous les
groupes qui ont participé à cet
amendement c'est un moment chaque mot
chacun des mots de cet amendement ont un
sens et je vous le donne je vous le lis
comme ça vous l'aurez en tête parce que
la discussion va visiblement être longue
vu le succès qui a cet amendement en
lire le nombre de sous amendements la
loi garantit l'effectivité et les
galaxies à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse chaque mot ont un sens
effectivement
la loi garantie on rapporte à la gloire
et ça peut rassurer Madame Le Pen
ensuite l'effectivité l'effectivité
c'est de donner des délais qui sont des
délais raisonnables et qui sont des
données des délais qui ne pourraient pas
être restreint on peut on ne pourrait
pas imaginer le Conseil constitutionnel
jugerait un
constitutionnel une loi qui donnerait
par exemple deux semaines de délai le
légal Access est pour rappeler la règle
républicaine de l'égal accès partout sur
le territoire et ensuite on reprend les
mots de Simone Veil et donc là on va
aussi dans le sens de républicain des
républicains interruption volontaire de
grossesse volontaires c'est la volonté
de la femme seulement elle et je
rappelle ce que nous disait Simone Veil
la femme ne doit pas porter seule la
responsabilité de ce soit ce poids mais
c'est son choix et donc cet amendement
est un amendement qui permettra je pense
d'avancer d'avancer vers les sénateurs
et pour conclure je laisserai vous aurez
le sous amendement de Philippe Vigier
qui est un signe supplémentaires vers
les vers les sénateurs pour mettre à
l'article créer un article 66-2 plutôt
que de la voir dans l'article 1 monsieur
Balanant l'a dit c'est donc un travail
transpartisant qui a été fait qui
retient une formule qui est une formule
positive c'est-à-dire la loi garantie
qui est une comprime réponse pour dire
que non nous n'inscrivons pas dans la
Constitution un droit qui serait
inconditionnel à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse mais qui serait
encadré par la loi et garantie par la
loi avec la question à la fois de
l'effectivité et de les galaxies ce qui
permet à la fois de penser la question
de l'effectivité du droit à l'avortement
avec notamment les déserts médicaux qui
pourraient ou les doubles clauses de
conscience qui pourraient empêcher des
femmes d'y aller mais qui pensaient qui
permet aussi par exemple d'empêcher des
régressions imaginons sur la gratuité
puisque par exemple cela voudrait dire
que seuls des femmes qui ont les
conditions financières et les réserves
financières pour le faire pourraient
alors y accéder donc ça permet de mettre
en quelque sorte une clause de non
régression sur cette question du droit à
l'IVG mais qui ne serait pas
inconditionnel contrairement à ce que
nous fait croire aujourd'hui notamment
les républicains là il est mis et
j'attire votre attention il est mis pour
l'instant à l'article premier l'article
premier l'idée c'était de dire que
l'article 1er régit en quelque sorte les
règles de base de notre communauté
politique et les droits sexuels et
reproductifs si évidemment là elle nous
parlons des droits des femmes sont aussi
une question d'égalité de citoyenneté
extrêmement importante et qui sont les
conditions même d'une reproduction d'une
communauté politique donc cela
permettrait de d'avoir à cet article
premier mais il y a un sous amendement
auquel je serai favorable qui le permet
de le mettre à l'article 66.2 à
l'article 66.2 qui permettrait peut-être
d'avoir un accord plus facile avec le
Sénat enfin dernière chose sur le 274 je
vais le retirer madame la Présidente au
vu du nombre de susam amendements qu'il
y a même si je regrette que le droit à
la perception et j'ai bien compris que
ça ne fera pas consensus ne soit pas
inscrit dans la Constitution la gueule
délégation des droits des fans s'il
était déclarés favorable et je rappelle
que en Pologne lorsque le droit à
l'avortement est attaqué et bien on sait
aussi la pilule du lendemain sans
ordonnance qui est interdite donc c'est
je crois que ce sont deux corollaires
mais je préfère le retirer pour éviter
l'obstruction parlementaire le
sous-amendement 587
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues alors qu'il nous reste des
centaines d'amendements à examiner dont
il faut le dire un certain nombre
d'entre eux vivent uniquement à polluer
ou à ralentir le débat je vous propose à
ce stade du débat un amendement
sous un manque à l'amendement de notre
collègue Balanant qui était déjà un
amendement consensuel sur la formulation
mais qui posait un certain nombre de
questions à différents groupes sur la
place dans le texte en effet il est
inscrit à l'article 1er et ce que je
vous propose c'est de le déplacer à
l'article 60 66 2 afin de trouver un
consensus qui viendrait à la fois
répondre aux exigences des uns et
excusez-moi madame la députée le 587
vous l'avez retiré vous défendez le 588
oui oui oui excusez-moi
donc je reprends alors nous sommes pas
tous d'accord sur cette emplacement à
titre personnel notre groupe porter
plutôt la position à l'article premier
mais dans les différents débats et dans
les débats en commission il nous
apparaît que la place à l'article 62 est
privilégié je rappelle aussi que
la proposition de Aurore berger fait
aussi état de setup lentement donc à ce
stade il nous apparaît beaucoup plus
consensuel de prendre la proposition de
formulation de notre collègue Balanant
et de le déplacer à l'article 66 2 ce
qui nous permettrait à la fois de
recueillir un consensus très large ici
et de voir prospérer cette formulation
et cet emplacement au Sénat avec
beaucoup plus de chances d'y parvenir
donc je vous propose à cet instant de
nous mettre d'accord à la fois sur cette
formulation et à la fois sur
l'emplacement je vous remercie merci
madame la députée avant de vous donner
la parole monsieur Vigier je rappelle
parce que les gens s'énervent en levant
la main pour que je donne la parole nous
sommes dans une très longue discussion
commune il n'y aura pas de prise de
parole tant que la discussion commune
est en cours merci cette réécriture de
l'article unique de la proposition de
loi constitutionnelle visa convaincre le
plus de députés possible de voter le
texte mais de convaincre aussi les
sénateurs très réticents à l'idée
d'inscrire dans la Constitution le droit
à l'IVG
simplement en cohérence avec toutes les
discussions que nous avons eu depuis le
début de la matinée sur ce texte
important sur le droit l'avortement le
garantir et le mettre dans le droit
constitutionnel simplement de précision
qui arrive le mot contraception je
voudrais simplement dire à tous les
collègues attentifs qu'ils sont que dans
le fameux pelletfs 2023 que beaucoup
n'ont pas voté la pilule de lendemain
l'interrupteur justement cette
possibilité de Neo femme en urgence
d'avoir un traitement a été validé par
l'Assemblée et le gouvernement qu'on le
sache bien c'est important
je vous remercie madame la rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente
able que nous avons trouvé sur les
différents bancs de l'hémicycle même si
je pense que dans une étape prochaine il
faudra inscrire et le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et le droit à la contraception parce que
ce sont des droits qui sont corollaires
et qui sont liés et notamment parce que
je le redis en Pologne et la délégation
des droits des femmes de manière trans
partisane la redit lorsqu'en Pologne on
attaque le droit et on entrave le droit
à l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
on interdit aussi la pilule du lendemain
sans ordonnance dernière chose Monsieur
de Philippot je le redis je vais le
redire pour la énième et dernière fois
quand vous écrivez la loi garantit
l'effectivité les galaxies au droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
ce que nous demandons avec la
constitutionnalisation de ce droit c'est
le droit à l'IVG tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
même si je suis partisane de la
suppression de la double clause de
conscience
je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente le
Gouvernement est favorable à
l'amendement déposé par monsieur le
député Philippe Vigier
pour le groupe les républicains pour une
durée de 5 minutes
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
avant tout je voudrais rappeler ici que
notre groupe au début de la discussion
de ce texte insister sur le fait que de
manière très claire nous étions attachés
à la loi veille du 17 janvier 1975 et
notamment à ses grands principes
c'est-à-dire y compris avec un certain
nombre d'évolutions qui ont pu avoir
lieu dès lors qu'elles ne remettent pas
en cause les grands principes et nous
proposions de constitutionnaliser ses
principes fondamentaux tant évidemment
sur le droit de la femme a demandé
l'interruption volontaire de grossesses
que de respecter évidemment le
commencement de la vie en proposant
d'inscrire dans la Constitution que nul
ne peut être privé du droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
en réalité on a assisté au cours des
débats à une évolution très claire qui
en réalité montre que les équilibres
fondamentaux qui sont vraiment les
principes de la loi Veil ne sont plus
respectés et à partir de là nous avions
nous considérer que il fallait en tout
cas faire en sorte qu'il y ait des
garanties que c'est garanti chouette
effectuées nous avons posé un certain
nombre de questions à Monsieur le garder
show concernant ces garanties et là nous
n'avons pas eu de réponse et c'est là
aussi nous avons été extrêmement surpris
collectivement de voir que on a expédié
en quelque sorte notre amendement qui
était un amendement qui permettait là
aussi de poser un certain nombre de
choses et c'est la raison pour laquelle
et bien notre groupe a poursuivi je
dirais les débats en posant des
questions qui sont restées hélas sans
réponse je voudrais terminer en disant
que très clairement sur les sujets
sociétaux notre groupe a toujours
considéré qu'il y avait liberté de vote
mais encore une fois ce que l'on peut
déplorer c'est que le gouvernement là
dessus a été extrêmement manichéen et
que encore une fois Monsieur le garder
show vous avez utilisé un certain nombre
d'arguments en disant il faut
constitutionnaliser et lorsque l'on
évoque un certain nombre de garanties
nécessaires pour maintenir l'équilibre
qui était vraiment la base même de la
loiveil et bien vous utilisez les mêmes
arguments pour dire le contraire et ça
ça interroge les interrogations
aujourd'hui sont quand même extrêmement
nombreuses et voir aujourd'hui cette
alliance entre la majorité
présidentielle le gouvernement et
évidemment la nu-pêche interroge une
fois de plus d'autant plus que il y a
des bruits qui circulent comme quoi
madame berger allait retirer le texte de
renaissance montrant une nouvelle fois
que là aussi il y a des choses qui en
réalité ne sont pas transparentes et qui
en réalité ne permettent pas un débat
éclairé
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Erwan Balanant pour le groupe
modem démocrate et un dépendant merci
madame la Présidente voilà nous avons eu
ce matin et en ce début d'après-midi un
débat riche et un débat je pense qui
fait honneur au travail parlementaire
on avait la chance d'avoir deux
propositions de loi sur le même sujet
proposition de loi de Madame panot et
proposition de loi de Madame berger
quelque part ça nous a donné un temps de
réflexion de travail double temps en
commission et et un travail qui a pu
être fait avec une recherche de
consensus nous nous y sommes arrivés
l'amendement qui a été voté tout à
l'heure qui est un amendement trans
partisan a été voté dans tous les
groupes à la majorité sauf un les
républicains
dans l'ensemble des groupes
majoritairement tout le monde a voté ce
dispositif donc nous montrons par ce
vote notre capacité à travailler
ensemble quand les sujets réclament le
dépassement des clivages et je pense
vraiment que par ce vote par ce travail
nous en aurons le travail nous en aurons
le skel au Parlement et nous donnons un
message aussi aux Français c'est-à-dire
que parfois au-delà de nos différences
au-delà de nos contradictions politiques
nous sommes en capacité d'aller dans le
sens
de la réponse la plus proche aux
préoccupations des Françaises et en
l'occurrence sur ce sujet aux
préoccupations des Françaises
notre texte est équilibré je le redis
par la définition de l'effectivité de
l'égalité nous nous gravons dans le
marbre la possibilité pour les femmes de
bénéficier de pouvoir
avoir ce droit ce droit à l'IVG et le
terme
IVG il est inscrit dans le marbre aussi
et c'est une référence forte une
référence historique à la loi veille la
loi veille c'était justement ça à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et je le redis au républicains qui ont
un peu tremblé aujourd'hui comme ils
avaient majoritairement tremblé
d'ailleurs en 75
le le
ce qui est écrit c'est interruption
volontaire de grossesse donc on laisse
évidemment
aux femmes la capacité la liberté de
choisir et c'est aussi ça que nous
apportons comme message après avoir
apporté un message aux Français par
cette capacité à travailler ensemble
nous apportons aussi un message au reste
du monde et cette loi est aussi une
réponse à la loi à la et aussi une
réponse à la décision de la Cour suprême
américaine dans notre pays nous
affirmons haut et fort que les droits
acquis par les femmes que les droits
acquis par les femmes et par les hommes
n'auront pas de régression et nous
continuerons le combat pour qu'elle
continue à avancer je remercie tous les
parlementaires qui ont travaillé sur ce
sujet aujourd'hui et les jours derniers
évidemment madame berger madame panot
madame rixin madame belfi stèle je vais
en oublier je madame bateau madame
je vais en oublier mais elle se
reconnaîtront merci à elle madame Elsa
fossillon
voilà est-ce que excusez moi
excusez-moi mes chers amis le moment est
important laissez-moi aller jusqu'au
bout j'avais prévu de faire moins tout
mais si vous voulez je peux aller
jusqu'au 5 minutes donc pour conclure
nous en aurons le travail parlementaire
par ce vote et continuons le combat
parce qu'il n'est pas fini il faudra
acquérir il faudra aller chercher la le
vote des sénateurs et après j'espère que
le gouvernement pourra reprendre ça à
son compte pour un projet de loi et je
remercie évidemment monsieur le garde
des sceaux pour son avis de sagesse mais
une sagesse bien éclairée sur les débats
d'aujourd'hui
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Marie Noël
Baptiste pour le groupe socialiste et à
part entière
oui merci madame la Présidente je
voulais aussi rappeler la notre pleine
satisfaction du groupe socialiste pour
l'adoption qui va je l'espère arriver
dans quelques minutes dans cette
hémicycle c'est un grand jour pour le
droit des femmes je crois que nous avons
su collectivement travailler à cette
adoption et je voulais ici remercier
l'ensemble des parlementaires de tous
les groupes politiques parce que je sais
que dans chacun des groupes il y a eu
des voix qui vont contribuer à cette
adoption je voulais aussi remercier les
rapporteurs de plusieurs textes dont
évidemment Mathilde panot qui rapporte
aujourd'hui celui-ci qui a permis un
travail collectif avec aussi de nombreux
groupes de l'Assemblée pour revenir sur
l'écriture de ce texte je le dirai
moi-même c'était pas mon écriture
privilégiée au départ mais en tout cas
c'est aussi le travail du Parlement que
d'être dans leur recherche d'une voix
consensuelle c'est ce que nous avons
fait remercier le garde des sceaux et
son écoute aujourd'hui pour pour cet
adoption remercie bien évidemment Aurore
berger qui a travaillé aussi sur un
texte qui nous a été proposé en
commission qui rejoint sur l'essentiel
cette proposition d'aujourd'hui en tout
cas je crois que avec nous tous ici
rassemblés nous allons pouvoir
contribuer à ce grand pas aujourd'hui
vers l'inscription de ce droit dans la
Constitution je crois que c'est vraiment
un jour extrêmement important pour le
droit des femmes alors maintenant
peut-être monsieur le garde des sceau je
me tourne vers vous pour vous dire que
nous comptons sur vous pour que vous
puissiez nous proposer un projet de loi
le plus rapidement possible pour que ce
soit vraiment une inscription définitive
dans la Constitution merci
toutes et tous
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Anne-Cécile
violent pour le groupe horizon et
parenté
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues
la rédaction que nous avons adopté à
recueillie effectivement des voix venues
de tous les groupes politiques de cette
assemblée et c'est une victoire c'est
d'abord et avant tout une victoire pour
toutes les femmes de France
c'est aussi une victoire légistique la
rédaction que nous venons d'adopter
préserve notre droit actuel et nous
oblige
elle nous oblige à nous assurer que ce
droit soit encore davantage effectif
qu'il soit accessible par toutes et sur
tout le territoire
c'est aussi une victoire humaniste parce
qu'elle est le fruit d'un travail
transpartisant qu'il faut souligner
notamment avec madame le rapporteur et
Monsieur Awans
nous nous réjouissons donc que la
rédaction sur laquelle nous nous
apprêtons à nous prononcer correspondant
tout point à la rédaction proposée par
notre amendement commun
le travail transpartisan qui s'est
engagé dès la commission des lois sur
les propositions de loi déposées tant
par Madame berger que par madame panot
est une preuve que nous sommes capables
de travailler tous ensemble au-delà des
clivages politiques lorsqu'il s'agit de
sujets aussi essentiels que la
constitutionnalisation du droit à l'IVG
au fantasme d'accord société
ce matin dont je n'ai pas tout à fait
compris le concept je veux opposer la
sagesse politique des députés qui ont su
dépasser leur clivage pour défendre ce
droit fondamental bien que nous
partageons pas la même vision de la
société
le groupe horizon et à parenté votre a
cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle telle qu'elle a été
amendée par notre assemblée je vous
remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Jérémy urdanov pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente
puis affligée vraiment affligé par
l'attitude et le niveau des débats sur
une partie de nos bancs
nos concitoyens jugeront
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame elsafossillon
pour le groupe de la Gauche démocrate et
républicaine merci madame la Présidente
je veux dire au nom du groupe GDR nups
notre émotion et notre fierté notre
conviction juste avant de voter ce texte
qui va permettre la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG on sait
que il y a encore du chemin pour que ce
soit réellement effectif nous sommes
déterminés à mener ce combat pour que ce
texte aille jusqu'au bout et nous le
voyons aussi comme un message un message
de soutien un message comme un plaidoyer
pour l'universalisme de ce droit et je
crois que notre détermination est bien
elle est aussi au service de toutes ces
femmes qui au travers du monde se
battent encore pour un droit à l'IVG je
pense au texane je pense au hongroise je
pense au malgache aux Italiens et c'est
aussi à elle qu'on dédie ce combat
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Benjamin saint
tui pour le groupe liberté indépendant
outre-mer et territoire
merci merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur ministre madame la rapporteur
je m'exprime en mon nom personnel et au
nom de l'immense majorité du groupe
liotte pour redonner d'abord un point de
méthode ce sera vrai pour elle ETI
aujourd'hui ce sera vrai pour les autres
niches parlementaires le groupe se
refuse à participer à une logique
d'obstruction nous avons un jour par
groupe et nous le resterons dans cette
situation pour permettre à chacun de
défendre ces options et de permettre
aussi à la représentation nationale de
pouvoir se positionner nous nous sommes
évidemment très attaché au droit des
femmes et à leur capacité à décider de
leur vie de disposer de leur corps et
évidemment cette discussion nous
l'attendions avec intérêt étant
conscient que au-delà de la niche NFI la
majorité présidentielle en tout cas le
groupe Renaissance avait prévu de
déposer le texte dans des conditions à
peu près similaires nous l'aurions très
largement très majoritairement voté et
donc nous le ferons aujourd'hui lui avec
force conscient que les Français en joie
dernier ont souhaité de fait une
représentation proportionnelle de
l'Assemblée nationale et qui nous
appartient donc en sagesse de créer les
conditions quand cela est possible de
convergence nous nous réjouissons
aujourd'hui que l'ensemble des bancs de
l'Assemblée en tout cas de seuls et ceux
qui ont travaillé à la rédaction de ce
texte et plus particulièrement de
l'amendement qui a permis la convergence
soit en situation d'être largement
majoritaire enfin je veux dire à
certains qui ont usé de faune et que
nous vous voyons il aura fallu il aura
fallu deux suspensions de séances au
rassemblement national pour savoir quoi
faire vous avez des colonnes vertébrales
de plastique comme la chef a changé vous
allez changer nous le regrettons mais
nous savons d'où vous venez faisons en
sorte de donner de la force à ce texte
pour qu'au Sénat enfin il trouve éco et
résonance merci à vous
peu avant le vote final la présidente du
groupe Renaissance à l'Assemblée
nationale annonce qu'elle retire sa
proposition de loi qui vise elle aussi à
inscrire le droit à l'IVG dans la
Constitution Aurore berger fait cause
commune avec sa collègue de la nupes en
évoquant le cas de sa mère qui a dû
avorter dans la clandestinité la parole
est un merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président la Commission des lois madame
la rapporteur
on a tous des héritages des héritages
personnels qui guident nos engagements
et qui doivent normalement guider les
raisons qui font que nous avons eu envie
de devenir parlementaire de nous exposer
et de solliciter le suffrage des
Français la question du combat des
droits des femmes de leur liberté de
leur émancipation a toujours été au cœur
des combats que j'ai menés avant de
revenir dans cette émission puisque je
n'avais pas tout avait prévu d'être là
cet après-midi j'ai appelé une seule
personne qui se trouve être ma maman
et si je vous parle d'elle c'est parce
qu'elle m'a donné l'autorisation de le
faire ma mère a eu recours à
l'avortement à un moment où c'était
illégal dans notre pays elle y a eu
recours comme peut-être un certain
nombre de nos maires de nos grands-mères
elle y a eu recours dans un moment où
elle risquait la prison et elle risquait
sa vie où elle a d'abord fait appel à un
médecin vraisemblablement à ses connu à
l'époque pour cela mais l'opération ne
s'est pas très bien passée et comme pour
de trop nombreuses femmes elle a dû
ensuite aller à l'hôpital à l'hôpital où
elle pensait trouver un refuge un refuge
bienveillant un refuge accueillant elle
a été reçue sous une forme d'inquisition
parce qu'on avait bien compris
évidemment l'acte qu'elle avait tenté de
réaliser à ce moment là
et alors alors qu'elle était dans les
mains de médecins et bien ce qui s'est
passé à ce moment là c'est qu'elle a en
effet pu mettre un terme à sa grossesse
mais qu'elle a subi un curetage sans
anesthésie voilà ce qui se passait voilà
ce que les femmes subissaient voilà ce
que nos maires ont pu subir voilà ce que
nos grands-mères ont pu subir la
question de l'accès à l'IVG la question
de sa protection c'est pas un caprice
c'est pas un gain politique c'est pas
une question de groupe politique les
Français on a cessé de le dire ici ont
d'ailleurs fait en sorte que nous ayons
une nouvelle assemblée et que nous
arrivions à démontrer que nous pouvions
travailler différemment c'est sur la
question des droits des femmes nous ne
sommes pas capables de le faire alors
nous serons capables de le faire sur
aucun texte et je crois que c'est la
démarche qui est la nôtre aujourd'hui
alors je le dis très clairement et très
nettement le texte que nous nous
apprêtons à voter et je l'espère avec la
plus large majorité possible aujourd'hui
ce texte là devient le texte de notre
assemblée devient le texte qui doit
toutes et tous nous réunir devient le
texte qui doit pouvoir aboutir parce que
nous ne devons pas finir notre mandat de
parlementaire sans que notre
Constitution ait été modifiée sans que
l'IVG ait été intégré à notre
Constitution c'est ça l'engagement que
nous devons prendre c'est ça
l'engagement que nous prenons
aujourd'hui en votant ce texte
en votant ce texte qui sera le texte
unique sur ce sujet alors je le dis de
manière claire
au nom de toutes les femmes au nom de
toutes nos mères qui se sont battus au
nom de toutes nos filles qui n'ont plus
jamais à devoir se battre je l'espère
oui je suis ici pour cela pour voter ce
texte et j'espère qu'il sera voté de
manière très large aujourd'hui
voilà le consensus est plutôt large pour
voter cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle à quelques réserves
près la parole est à Madame Pascal bord
pour le groupe rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente
chers collègues il nous faut rester
vigilante car nous avons évité le pire
aujourd'hui oui le texte initial qui
était proposé
avait pour objet de créer un droit
inconditionnel à l'IVG et de faire en
sorte que certaines femmes puissent
avorter à 8 ou 9 mois ce qui est
inadmissible et totalement
inenvisageable
ce texte ce texte
marque pour moi une défaite cuisante de
la gauche de cette gauche radicale et
radicalisée qui n'a pour boussole que la
fin de notre monde la fin du monde tel
que nous le connaissons
[Applaudissements]
c'est grâce effectivement à un travail
transpartisant c'est grâce à la
mandement de Marine Le Pen que la
majorité que la majorité a réécrit
rapidement très rapidement son texte
texte qui sera soumis dans quelques
instants au vote c'est devant devant
effectivement cette réécriture
cette réécriture qui qui est un moindre
mal Marine Le Pen a effectivement retiré
son amendement
le texte le texte voté
ne change rien en termes de droit
puisqu'il renvoie à la loi mais ça n'est
pas je vous le rappelle une protection
absolue c'est la raison pour laquelle il
nous faudra rester de tout temps
extrêmement vigilant ce texte je vous le
disais est un moindre mal je souhaite en
terminer en indiquant à nos concitoyens
en indiquant aux Français qu'ils peuvent
comme ils l'ont toujours fécompté sur
nous pour défendre leurs droits tout
leur droit et notamment le pouvoir
d'achat puisque elle est fille a eu
l'indécence de supprimer de la liste des
textes à examiner le texte sur le SMIC
alors alors que nos concitoyens
alors que nos concitoyens ont d'autres
soucis aujourd'hui que le texte sur
l'IVG qui est certes un texte important
mais moins important que le pouvoir
d'achat pour la totalité de nos
concitoyens
qui pourront toujours tenter sur nous
proposition de loi constitutionnelles
très largement votée en séance publique
ce 24 novembre 2022 pour inscrire le
droit à l'avortement dans la
Constitution une belle unanimité saluée
par celle qui a porté le texte n'a-t-il
panot je vais donner la parole pour
quelques mots successivement madame la
rapporteur monsieur le président de
commission et enfin Monsieur le Ministre
merci madame la Présidente collègue je
suis très très émue à la fois de ce vote
et de ce signal historique
que l'Assemblée nationale sonore a
envoyé à toutes les femmes de notre pays
mais aussi à l'ensemble des femmes du
monde
je suis très émue de voir que malgré
l'obstruction qui n'en a pas terminé
jusqu'à son terme nous avons su dégager
collectivement un consensus avec la
conscience du temps long persuadé que
nous faisons acte de progrès pas
seulement pour nous-mêmes mais aussi
pour les générations à venir
aujourd'hui collègue l'Assemblée
nationale par le monde aujourd'hui
collègues notre pays par le monde
la France en introduisant le droit à
l'avortement dans la Constitution serait
la nation pionnière en matière des
droits des femmes il est temps que notre
pays s'affirme comme à l'avant-garde de
la protection des droits sexuels et
reproductifs monsieur le ministre
maintenant la balle est dans le camp du
gouvernement nous espérons et nous
sommes nombreuses à l'espérer nous
espérons un projet de loi
constitutionnel qui nous permettent
d'aller plus rapidement sur cette
question
je veux ici remercier chaleureusement et
sincèrement l'ensemble des collègues
députés qui ont permis de recueillir la
sentiment de leur groupe et de
travailler à cette formulation
transparisane je remercie Mélanie Vogel
qui courentusement au Sénat à porter
cette question il y a un mois je
remercie évidemment l'administrateur
monsieur Joly mais l'ensemble aussi des
services de l'assemblée qui ont fait un
travail remarquable je veux enfin dédier
cette victoire historique que nous
envoyons à la fois comme signal à notre
pays mais au monde aux femmes des
États-Unis aux femmes de Pologne aux
femmes de Hongrie dont le droit à
l'avortement et aujourd'hui on travaille
mais aussi et elles sont là aujourd'hui
aux militants qui dans notre pays
lutte au quotidien pour le droit des
femmes à disposer de leur corps je vous
remercie
merci
monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
je voudrais d'abord m'associer aux mots
qui viennent d'être dit par les
différents orateurs et notamment par la
rapporteur sur le message historique que
la France délivre à la phase du monde et
principalement quand on connaît les
attaques que nous avons rappelé
principalement quand on connaît aussi
notre histoire puisque c'est 50 ans
après le procès de Bobigny j'ai
l'occasion de le dire au début de cette
discussion ce que je voudrais vous dire
aussi
c'est ce que nous non de beauté ce n'est
pas le point final
et ce que nous avons fait nous pouvons
le faire y compris sans attendre un
projet de loi du gouvernement c'est pour
ça qu'il était aussi essentiel aussi
essentiel
de réécrire le texte que vous nous
proposez
d'être parfois un peu plus prudent même
si nous ne renonçons à rien sur la
contraception c'est pour ça qu'il était
aussi essentiel de pouvoir inscrire ces
dispositions dans le corps même de la
Constitution et non seulement en son
article premier et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons ouvert la voie
à un débat dans la haute chambre un
débat qui nous implique tous puisque
auprès des groupes
qui nous représente également auprès de
cette chambre nous avons une
responsabilité un débat qui nous
implique tout et pour lequel je prendrai
ma part en prendront notamment à tâche
avec le président de la commission des
Lois du Sénat pour que ce texte chemine
et je vous invite vraiment à considérer
qu'il ne s'agit là en dépit du fait
qu'il s'agit d'un grand pas que d'un
premier pas je vous remercie
merci
la parole est à Monsieur le Ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés
je prends acte avec beaucoup de
solennités de gravité du vote historique
qui vient d'avoir lieu il y a de cela
quelques minutes
j'ai tout à l'heure dans mon discours
appelé de mes vœux que l'Assemblée
nationale se prononce pour l'inscription
de l'IVG dans notre Constitution
c'est désormais chose faite et bien
faite avec une très large majorité
grâce à la majorité et je veux saluer
ici
Aurore berger
je sais
et il m'est pénible de vous vous soyez à
cet instant
l'engagement
viscéral personnel
qui est le vôtre
et je veux saluer ce très grand geste du
retrait du texte que vous avez préparé
de très longues dates
je veux également bien sûr et je
n'oublierai
personne saluait
le modèle
horizon bien sûr
merci pour cet engagement
c'est l'expression au fond de nos
valeurs communes
grâce à l'opposition également mais en
particulier à la gauche et je veux
saluer le travail de madame la
Présidente panneau aussi les groupes
socialistes
écologistes communistes et je n'oublie
pas bien sûr les membres du groupe liote
[Applaudissements]
l'assemblée mesdames et messieurs les
députés
envoient aujourd'hui un message fort et
je voudrais vous dire que c'est un grand
honneur et une grande émotion pour moi
d'être parmi vous et d'avoir
porté le soutien indéfectible du
gouvernement vous le savez je l'ai dit
une révision constitutionnelle ça se
fait avec l'accord des deux chambres il
reviendra bien sûr au Sénat de se
prononcer le moment venu sur le fruit de
nos débats pour que nous poursuivions
cette navette parlementaire sur la
rédaction d'un texte qui marque
évidemment une étape fondamentale pour
le renforcement du droit à l'IVG
quoi qu'il en soit nous réaffirmons que
les femmes disposent de leur corps et
une fois encore point final
voilà alors le parcours législatif est
loin d'être achevé pour cette
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
mais le symbole est là elle a été
présentée 48 ans après le vote
historique à l'Assemblée nationale de la
loi veille qui a dépénalisé l'avortement
en France vous voyez d'ailleurs derrière
moi une sculpture réalisée à l'effigie
de Simone Veil dans les jardins de
l'Assemblée nationale c'est la fin de
cette émission on se retrouve très vite
sur LCP pour revoir un autre moment
parlementaire